[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts transfiguration
professor
and later headmistress minerva
mcgonagall
maneuver mcgonagall is a scottish
half-blood witch that attended hogwarts
school
of witchcraft and wizardry her age is a
bit unclear
and actually a bit of a cannon blunder
in fantastic piece too
the crimes of grindelwald we see a
younger mcgonagall
who appears to be in her 20s or so but
this is not consistent with what jk
rowling had revealed about mcgonagall
in the original series originally
rowling stated that mcgonigle started
teaching at the school
in 1956 at the age of 21
however fantastic beast 2 takes place in
the year 1927.
it just doesn't really add up in a 1995
conversation between umbridge and
mcgonagall
mcgonagall reveals that she had been
working at hogwarts 39 years
this december which is consistent with
what rowling had said
initially anyway moving on mcgonagall is
a half-blood
which means that she was born to one
magical and one non-magical parent
her parents were muggle robert mcconnell
in which isabelle ross
she also had two brothers malcolm and
robert jr
minerva had a bit of an interesting
upbringing because her father
never knew that her mother isabelle was
a witch isabelle could not bring herself
to
ma the bliss of the honeymoon by telling
her smitten new husband
that she had graduated top of her class
in charms at hogwarts
nor that she'd been captain of the
school quidditch team after isabel fell
in love with robert
she gave up magic in pursuit of a normal
life with her muggle love interest
and she never revealed to him that she
was magical after being happily married
for some time
isabelle eventually became pregnant with
their firstborn
minerva mcgonagall when minerva was born
however
it occurred to isabel that mcgonagall
may very well show signs
of magical ability she was a witch after
all
eventually as she had predicted minerva
began to show signs of magic
mcgonagall began doing things that no
normal muggle child could do
like summoning toys to herself and
making the family cat do her bidding
it was at this point that isabelle knew
that she would have to tell her husband
about her background she would have to
tell him that she was a witch
after isabelle told robert they stayed
together but their trust
never was the same which had a huge
impact on the family
robert didn't have any inherent problem
with her being magical
but the fact that their relationship was
based largely on a lie
was an issue for him it was a really sad
situation as they truly loved each other
but it was hard for him to come to terms
with it was a hard time for the family
as a whole and as you might have
expected minerva's siblings
robert and malcolm also turned out to be
magical robert senior was the only
muggle
despite increased family tension
mcgonagall became very close with her
father
as she got older and even though he
wasn't magical and couldn't relate to
mcgonagall in that same way
she was still closer with him than with
her mother she was also said to resemble
him
in temperament like most other witches
and wizards mcgonagall attended hogwarts
herself
and like dumbledore and tom riddle she
was the most talented student of her
entire year
she achieved top grades in her newts and
owls and showed powerful magical ability
from a very young
age showing a particular affinity for
transfiguration
which we know she later teaches shortly
after arriving at the school
she went to the sorting ceremony where
students are sorted into their
respective houses
mcgonagall sorting proved to be a rare
occasion as she was a
hatsu something that only occurs once
every 50 years or so
this is when the sorting hat takes
longer more than five minutes to be
exact
to make its decision it occurs when a
student has a personality that could be
considered equally suitable for more
than one house
and in mcgonagall's case the hat
deliberated for five and a half minutes
on whether she should be placed in
gryffindor or ravenclaw
she was eventually sorted into
gryffindor when mcgonagall was finished
studying at hogwarts
her future looked bright as she had
continually impressed her professors and
peers
while attending the school upon
graduation she was offered a position at
the department of magical law
enforcement
in the ministry of magic the department
of the ministry responsible
for upholding wizarding law however
before starting in her new role
she returned to her parents home for the
summer to spend time with her family
it was during the summer that mcgonagall
first met dougal mcgregor
a clever handsome muggle farmer who
lived in the same town
the two instantly hit it off showing
common interests
a sense of humor and just an overall
outlook on life the pair got along so
well in fact
that mcgregor eventually proposed to
mcgonagall without hesitation
mcgonagall accepted his offer but as
some time passed
she began to truly consider the
implications of marrying dougal
you see similar to the situation with
her parents mcgonagall had failed to
inform dougal
that she was in fact a witch this was
the exact mistake that her mother
had made with her father and mcgonagall
saw firsthand the impact that this had
on their family
mcgonagall was a talented young witch
with a promising future at the ministry
of magic
and telling dougal that she was magical
would have jeopardised this future
breaking laws pertaining to the
international statute of secrecy
if she told him that she was magical she
would be breaking wizarding law
and throwing away her future job and if
she didn't tell them that she was
magical
and they wed anyway it could mean
following her mother's unhappy footsteps
she could not bear the thought of
ruining her future family in a similar
fashion
when mcgonagall's mother isabelle told
her father robert that she was a witch
it had a profound impact on the family
their trust and their relationship
minerva who saw all of this unfold
firsthand decided that marrying dougal
was not the right thing to do
as mcgonagall could not marry dougal she
needed to break things off
but the worst part of all of it was that
mcgonagall could not even give him the
real reason why
three days after accepting his initial
proposal she met with dougal and
informed him of her revised decision she
told him she could not marry him
and left the village shortly after in
pursuit of her new career
though she was starting an exciting new
position at the ministry of magic
this was one of the hardest periods of
her life dougal
unable to accept that mcgonagall would
leave so easily fought for her
and sent mcgonagall letters for a long
time hoping to win her back
however mcgonagall knew that she could
never be with dougal
she saw how destructive her mother's
situation had been on her family
and it just wasn't an option for her
dougal however
did hold a very special place in
mcgonagall's heart for the rest of her
life
and she kept dougal's letters under her
bed in her hogwarts quarters
after leaving for london minerva began
working at the ministry of magic
her initial time at her new workplace
was difficult as she was still suffering
from the decision that she made
regarding mcgregor
at this point in time there was still
more of a distinct divide between the
wizarding and muggle worlds
and there was definitely more prejudice
towards muggles and muggle-borns
some of her co-workers at the ministry
had a very low perception of muggles
and a minerva who was very close with
her father and even fell in love with
the mughal
did not enjoy this environment in spite
of everything she still excelled in her
work
as she had always been an exceptional
student hard worker and innately very
magically talented
her work ethic eventually garnered her
the attention and respect of her older
boss
elfinstone urquhart however after some
time at ministry
mcgonagall began to miss her family and
home in scotland
and expressed to erkhardt that she would
soon be living the ministry
in response to this urcot tried to offer
her promotion to keep her around
this was an offer that she politely
declined but though she wanted to return
home
she didn't want to stop working
altogether which led to her application
at hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry almost instantly
mcgonagall was offered a posting in the
transfiguration department the best part
about it
she would be working directly under
transfiguration department head
albus dumbledore when she returned home
she was devastated to hear that her
former love interest
dougal mcgregor had gotten married with
another local knowing that she turned
him away without ever giving him a
proper explanation
she wallowed in her sorrow and knew that
she would have to accept how things had
turned out
in short stories from hogwarts of
heroism hardship and dangerous hobbies
a trio of ebooks published by pottermore
it's actually revealed that mcgregor was
eventually randomly murdered by death
eaters
during the 1970s amidst the first
wizarding war later in life
mcgonagall felt additional guilt of
leaving dougal as she wondered if he
would have survived
had they gotten married anyway after
minerva found out that dougal had
remarried
albers dumbledore who was her boss
comforted her on the night that she
found out
helping to form the strong relationship
that the two would go on to have
when the first wizarding war broke out
in the year 1970
mcgonagall continued teaching at
hogwarts but also helped out with the
efforts against voldemort and the death
eaters when she could
she chose not to join dumbledore's
outfit the order of the phoenix
and instead spied for the ministry of
magic in her animagus form
tabby cat she would spy on death eaters
and relay information to auras
at the ministry she managed to survive
the first war without any personal
injury
but did suffer the loss of her brother
robert mcgonagall
and many others after the war she
continued working as usual
minerva enjoyed her role at hogwarts
immensely she was a strict
but fair professor with a passion for
transfiguration
however despite cutting ties with the
ministry minerva's former boss elfin
stone urcat
would contact her frequently what a
maneuver didn't know was that
urcard wasn't contacting her for
professional reasons we see
he was in love with her when visiting
mcgonnell at the hogwarts grounds one
day
he proposed to her but mcgonagall still
processing the pain of losing dougal to
another woman
had to turn down his offer eventually
however after the first pushing war had
ended
elfinstone got through to her he would
frequently visit minerva and incessantly
proposed for years
unable to accept the fact that she would
not be with him finally around the year
when mcgonagall was certain that she was
finally over mcgregor she accepted his
offer
and the pair got engaged while strolling
around the lake near the hogwarts
grounds
after their engagement a retired
urquhart bought a cottage for them to
live in hogsmeade
not far from the school so that she
could easily travel to work
this was one of the happiest moments of
mcgonagall's life however
it was short-lived as tragedy struck her
once more
in the year 1985 after just a few years
of living together urkhart suddenly and
tragically passed away
from a venomous tentacular bite after
his death
maneuver couldn't bear to live in their
cottage alone and moved back into her
quarters at hogwarts school
after elfinstone died she poured
everything into her work and quietly
suffered
she was a brave and private person and
the only person who ever really learned
of her previous hardships
was albus dumbledore in whom she
confided
nothing particularly eventful occurred
between 1985
when mcgonagall moved back to the castle
in 1991 when none other than harry
potter began attending the school
when harry started there mcgonagall was
fully aware of his past
like everyone else and because she
shared a close connection with both of
his parents
she became a sort of distant guardian
for harry she could not openly choose
favorite students
but could she do it secretively
certainly she gave harry a hard time
but she was really really fond of him
and always made exceptions for him where
she could
mcgonagall like dumbledore quietly
watched over harry for the duration of
his time at the school
and even secretively gifted harry in
nimbus 2000
after he made the gryffindor quidditch
team in her youth mcgonagall played
quidditch herself
and had a strong desire for gryffindor
to beat out their rivals
slytherin during the years that harry
attended hogwarts
a lot happened particularly as 1991
marked the beginning of the first signs
of voldemort's resurgence
and 1995 marked the official beginning
the second wizarding war
with everything going on mcgonagall
would also help out where she could
and even ended up joining the second
resurgence of the order of the phoenix
she spent the entire summer of 1995
doing background work for the order
and this occupied a lot of her time
however
it wasn't until the 95-96 school year
that mcgonagall really had to deal with
a lot
you see the 95-96 school year was the
same year that umbridge
showed up mcgonagall had a lot of back
and forth with umbridge and ridley did
not approve of her posting at the school
given that she was unimpressed with her
presence at the school period i'm sure
you can imagine how unimpressed she was
when dumbledore was ousted and umbridge
took his place as headmistress
during this time she quietly undermined
umbridge and protected students and
fellow professors
when she could is it true that you
shouted at professor umbridge
yes said harry you called her a liar
yes you told her he who must not be
named is back
yes professor mcgonagall sat down behind
her desk
frowning at harry then she said i have a
biscuit to potter
after the umbrage escapade was over and
dumbledore was reinstated
the school began to face increasingly
difficult situations
the dark lord and his followers were
going in power and eventually
dumbledore was no longer around this
meant that voldemort and his followers
seized control of hogwarts and a
convincing double agent snape
was the new headmaster mcgonagall
remained professor during this time
most likely so that she could protect
students and really information to the
order
when harry ron and hermione returned to
the school in secret
they informed mcgonagall of their
mission from dumbledore and her response
to this
was that she would try her best to hold
voldemort and his army back for them
this prompted the epic defense of
hogwarts in which mcgonagall uses her
transfiguration ability
to bring all sorts of statues to life
hogwarts is threatened
man the boundaries protect us do your
duty to our school
mcgonagall alongside the other
professors fortified the castle
and fought valiantly at the battle of
hogwarts mcgonagall was also present for
voldemort's defeat
and in an uncharacteristic display of
emotion hugged harry in relief
after the war had ended mcgonagall was
offered the order of merlin first class
by the new minister for magic kingsley
shacklebolt and just four short months
after that
mcgonagall who was more suitable for the
role than anyone was appointed the new
hogwarts headmistress
mcgonagall presided over hogwarts
students beginning the 1998-1999 school
year
and after her promotion moved into
dumbledore's old quarters
as she had given up her transfiguration
posting she was now responsible for
among other things finding her
replacement you might also remember that
mcgonagall served as a special messenger
for hogwarts and would travel to the
homes of prospective muggleborn students
and inform their families of their
child's magical abilities
this task was eventually handed off to
rubius hagrid which is
questionable given his immense size and
initial shock value
mcgonagall is the current serving
hogwarts headmistress and
provided that she is still quite young
for which i imagine she will serve
for many years to come and that's it for
this video
did you guys know all this about
mcgonagall did anything shock you
if so what let me know down in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
[Music]
you